at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal questions
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
books i've loved on the tim ferriss show
is exclusively brought to you by
audible there couldn't be a better
sponsor for this series my dear
listeners and readers
i have used audible for so many years as
long as i can remember i love it
audible has the largest selection of
audiobooks on the planet i listen when
i'm taking walks
i listen while i'm cooking i listen
whenever i can
and if you're looking for a place to
start i can recommend three of my
favorites
the first is the tao of seneca
by seneca if you want to hear my
favorite letters of all time
touches on stoic philosophy calmness
under duress
etc the next is the graveyard book by
neil
gaiman g-a-i-m-a-n one of my favorites
even if you're a non-fiction
purist this is the fiction book that you
need to listen to
neil also has perhaps the most calming
voice of all time
and third greg mcewen's essentialism
subtitled the disciplined pursuit of
less this is one of my favorite books of
the past few years combines
very well with the 80 20 principle but
more on audible
every month audible members get one
credit for any audio book on the site
plus a choice of multiple audible
originals from a rotating selection they
also get access to daily news digests
from the likes of the new york times
wall street journal and the washington
post
as well as guided meditation programs
and here are some other amazing audible
features and i use a bunch of these you
can download titles and listen offline
anytime
anywhere i use this feature
even when i could get access i'll put my
phone on say airplane mode
because i don't want to get bothered
with notifications and i'm taking a walk
to clear my head
and you can listen to your titles
offline in a case like that or on a
plane or whatever obviously i'm not
flying much these days
the app is free and can be installed on
all smartphones and tablets you can
listen across devices without losing
your spot
and whispersync is another feature i use
quite a lot i love reading my kindle in
bed for instance
then picking up at the same exact spot
where i left off when i go walking and
listening the next day
kindle and audio versions can be synced
up automatically it's just amazing
and if you can't decide what to listen
to don't sweat it you don't have to rush
you can keep your credits for up to a
year and use them
for instance to binge on a whole series
if you like audible offers just about
everything podcasts
guided wellness programs theatrical
performances a-list comedy and audible
originals you won't find
anywhere else and right now audible is
offering you guys
that's tim ferriss show listeners a free
audio book with a
30-day trial membership and
again my list if you want to check them
out the tao of seneca
the graveyard book essentialism those
are just three there's so many good ones
out there
just go to audible.com tim
and browse the unmatched selection of
audio programs
then download your free title and start
listening it's that easy let's check it
out go to audible.com
tim or text tim tim to
500 500 to get started today check it
out
audible.com tim
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show
where it is usually my job to sit down
with world-class performers of all
different types
startup founders investors chess
champions olympic athletes you name it
to tease out the habits that you can
apply in your own lives
this episode however is an experiment
and part of a short form series that i'm
doing
simply called books i've loved i've
invited some amazing past
guests close friends and new faces to
share their favorite books
describe their favorite books the books
that have influenced them changed them
transform them for the better and i hope
you pick up one or two
new mentors in the form of books from
this new series and apply the lessons in
your own life
i had a lot of fun putting this together
inviting these people to participate
and have learned so so much myself i
hope that is also the case for you
please enjoy
hi tim ferriss listeners it's whitney
cummings uh thank you so much for
letting me do this tim um i'm only
picking two books
uh because i just wanted to keep it kind
of short and sweet
the first one that i wanted to suggest
is a book
by gavin to becker it's called the gift
of fear survival signals that protect us
um it's a lot about you know stalkers
and violence and stuff like that but
there's
um a lot of invaluable advice
around hiring people and drawing
boundaries with people
vetting people um for
people that want to be highly productive
for people that want to
have their weekends off for people who
want to have a drama-free workplace for
people who don't want to spend their
time and emotional energy on difficult
people
this is a this is a pretty
transformative book in terms of learning
how to trust your gut and not
dismiss red flags or write them off
you know i spent a lot of time working
with
people that were exhausting egomaniacs
difficult people people who would be
kind of a time suck in terms of
managing their emotions or you know
people that interpreted constructive
criticism as rejection and then i felt
like i had to take care of their
feelings and
and this and that i mean for someone
that has those feelings i also recommend
melanie beatty's book um codependent no
more
and the adult shot of alcoholics big
book aca big book
um but if you've done that work and you
know you're not being codependent and
turns out someone's just being really
difficult
and this book is pretty wonderful for
not dismissing your own gut
instincts because a lot of times when
someone's difficult you want to go well
i'm probably just being sensitive or i
probably was
too harsh or i probably should have
handled it this way or i shouldn't have
sent an email that was that
direct when you start blaming yourself
um
there's a something i want to read to
you uh
so i can start getting more specific on
123 page 123
of the gift of fear he writes if you
tell someone 10 times
that you don't want to talk to him you
are talking to him
nine more times than you wanted to if
you call him back after he leaves 20
messages you simply teach him
the cost of getting a call back is 20
messages
i love that because i don't think i
understood that
setting a boundary isn't always setting
a boundary
it's setting about you for yourself you
know if someone doesn't respect your
boundary you don't just keep setting the
boundary you just have to completely
disengage with the person if they don't
have the emotional intelligence acumen
or the ability to
to read a situation in a way that's
appropriate and it took me a long time
to stop engaging in inappropriate
behavior at the workplace
for me if some if it was like okay i
just have to spend an hour every day
with this person to get them to act the
way i want them to
that's an hour more a day that i need to
be spending with this person so
this book really helped me understand
that sometimes the only way to win is to
not play
um you know sometimes the best strategy
is a masterful retreat
when it comes to crazy people that are
just not able to
take a hint um so i highly recommend
digging into that
uh chapter there's a great story about
this uh
person who was at a workplace who was
becoming a problem and um i highly
recommend that i also earmarked
uh page 158 for some reason and oh yes i
did it's about um
references uh when you're working with
people getting references you know i've
made a lot of hiring mistakes because
i tend to hire people because we get
along really well we have really good
chemistry
or like this person's so funny or you
know we're both from dc
or you know like we've all had uh those
things where we want to hire someone
that we actually should have just been
friends with instead of someone we
should actually
be working with you know eight hours a
day in high stakes situations um
i've made this mistake before i used to
never ask around about people
i used to never get references i used to
never call like you'd see references on
a resume and you'd be like oh well
obviously if their numbers there that
counts that's easy enough
i think you know i like to now spend way
more time
hiring uh it helps me save time later
in in drama frankly so on 158
the failure to take the obvious step of
calling references is an epidemic in
america and i have little patience for
managers who complain about employees
that didn't care enough to assess before
hiring a common excuse for this failure
is the
references will say only good thing
since the candidate has prepared them
for the call
in fact there is a tremendous amount of
information to be gained from references
in terms of confirming facts
on an application did you know him when
he worked for such and such firm
when did he work for such and such firm
do you know roughly what salary he was
making
do you know what school he went to you
said you went to school with him i
suggested questions asked of those
listed as references be guided by
information on the application the most
important thing references can give you
are other references we call these
people developed sources these are
people who know the applicant but whom
he did not list
as references accordingly they are not
prepared for your inquiry and will be
more likely to provide valuable
information
you get the names of developed sources
by asking the references the applicant
listed
for the names of the people who know him
i'm reading that now and for some reason
it sounds really hard to understand
but it basically means ask the
references for other references so it's
people that weren't
necessarily prepared for your call do
research before you hire people the same
way you would vet someone you date
someone you marry someone you have in
your home vet people that you work with
it'll save you a lot of time
and emotional energy in the long run and
you will be more prolific
productive and happy on page 282 there's
a great
section on public speaking you know a
lot of people these days if you're
starting a business
you want to be a performer uh if you
want to be an entrepreneur
you have to be able to speak in public
and i think even now if you only want to
be a behind-the-scenes business person
investor whatever you also have to speak
at panels you have to do ted talks you
have to do a youtube channel you know
public speaking now isn't really
optional um
social media youtube so there's kind of
a great
section on that um and it's a section
that's about like rules
uh what you fear is rarely what you
think you fear
it's what you link to fear there's a
whole section about fear and public
speaking
quote surveys have shown that ranking
very close to the fear of death
is the fear of public speaking why would
someone feel profound fear
deep in his or her stomach about public
speaking which is so far from death
because it isn't so far from death when
we link it those who fear public
speaking
actually fear the loss of identity that
attaches to performing badly
and that is firmly rooted in our
survival needs for all social animals
from ants to antelopes identity is the
past card to inclusion
and inclusion is the key to survival if
a baby loses its identity
as the child of its parents a possible
outcome is abandonment
for a human infant that means death as
adults without our identity as a member
of the tribe or village
community or culture a likely outcome is
banishment and death so fear of getting
up and addressing 500 people
and the annual convention of
professionals in your field is not just
the fear of embarrassment it's linked to
the fear of being perceived as
incompetent
which is linked to the fear of loss of
employment loss of home loss of family
your ability
to contribute to society your value in
short your identity and your life
linking an unwarranted fear is the
ultimate terrible destination that
usually helps alleviate that fear
then you may find that public speaking
can link to death you'll see that that
would be
a long and unlikely trip just a really
great
uh chapter on fear and um
public speaking and sort of how we link
things in our brains
and uh that stuff just fascinates me and
i think is really important for anyone
that wants to be
successful quite frankly so highly
recommend the gift of fear by gavin to
becker the second book i'm going to
recommend
is a title that i just
hardly can say out loud it's so
embarrassing but it is such an
incredible book it is called getting the
love you want
a guide for couples i can't even say it
without laughing
um i remember when i first bought this
book i had to do it in person it was
like kind of before amazon and i went to
barnes noble back when that was a
store and i went up to the guy and i was
like can i get this book it's called
getting to love you like i had to
whisper it in the bookstore i was so
embarrassed to say it
and then he said it over the loudspeaker
he was like getting the love you want
aisle two
it was very embarrassing but the book is
so unbelievable it's by harvard
hendricks and helen
kelly lahunt i mean harvard hendricks is
um really famous for developing a [ __ ]
therapy
and before i read a chapter to you i
think
you know i talk about this a lot but i
think that the relationship you're in
is a business decision i know most of
tim ferriss's listeners are chiming in
for great business advice
productivity advice the person you
choose to be your partner
is a business decision the amount of
money that you're um
you know saving depends on that person
the amount of time you're putting in
your business depends on that
that choice the amount of emotional
energy that you have it depends on that
choice the amount of support you get you
know i feel very strongly that in order
to be
you know brave and take risks in your
professional life you have to have a
very stable safe
supportive personal life so i'm a big
fan of
anyone that wants to achieve wildly
astronomical goals uh you have to make
sure that your
home is in order as well and that your
heart is in order
um i think it's important that anybody
that wants to be successful in any part
of their lives understands
neurology and neurochemistry you guys
have heard me blather on about this
um on page 45 of getting the love you
want
what causes the rush of good feelings
that we all call romantic love
scientists who study natural hormones
and chemicals tell us that lovers are
literally high on drugs substances that
flood their bodies with a sense
of well-being during the attraction
phase of a relationship the brain
releases more dopamine and
norepinephrine two of the body's
neurotransmitters
these chemicals help contribute to a
rosy outlook on life a rapid pulse
increased energy and a sense of
heightened perception
oxytocin is enhanced as well as a potent
hormone that plays a role in many
aspects of our lives including
childbirth nursing orgasm and bonding
of mother and child and social
connections between individuals some
refer to it as the love sex hormone
during the phase when lovers want to be
together every moment of the day the
brain also ramps up its production of
endorphins natural narcotics that
enhance the sense of security and
comfort
um you guys might know this on some
level but i think it's really important
that people
understand that you know
being in love being attracted to
somebody being in a new intense
passionate relationship you're literally
high on drugs
uh it can be a huge distraction to your
work life
um if it ends up lasting that's great
but for the most part i've worked
you know a lot of people ask me uh how
do you do work so hard how do you have
so much time i really try to limit the
amount of uh
in my past um rampant love affairs
because most of it
is just neurochemicals not everyone is
the one and that's okay
but i think um really intense passionate
relationships can be a giant
distraction um ultimately from the goals
that you want to achieve so i always uh
think it's important that people really
understand
you know because you can meet someone
and then lose four months of your life
to someone that you're like i don't even
like that person i was just high on
neurochemicals that was a big waste of
time so i think that
you know we learn something from every
relationship we're in but i see a lot of
people's
careers suffering because they get
distracted
by relationships that ultimately don't
yield that much
and lessons that they quite frankly
don't need to learn
um page 73 there's a great chapter on
the stages of a power struggle in a
relationship
when you and your partner immersed in a
power struggle you have little sense of
when it all started or how it will end
but from
an outside perspective the power
struggle has predictable course one that
parallels the well-documented stages of
grief
in a bereaved person i'm not going to
read that whole chapter to you but
that's a really interesting one
and then on page 115 uh
there's a big chapter on empathizing and
being able to see
your partner's inner world to understand
you know because sometimes we say
something and it's not
perceived the way we intend it to be
received and we get so confused
how can they not understand we're saying
because they're seeing it through the
lens of their own experience
trauma uh parenting and neurology so
there's a great
exercise on how to empathize with your
partner and when you're
in a disagreement you repeat what the
other person says it's a pretty great
exercise
um because you know how often are we in
relationships and we say something and
the other person completely contorts it
and twists it you're like that's not
what i said and then
you start fighting about fighting
uh you're not even um fighting about the
thing anymore like what were you even
fighting about
uh so what you do to minimize the amount
of time that you're in
one of these altercations or power
struggles um if i say
i'm uncomfortable that you showed up
late the other person has to say
i hear that you're uncomfortable that i
showed up late but this this and this
and then i have to go well i hear that
this this and this but
you know so you have to mirror what the
other person says so that you're
actually having a productive
conversation that just doesn't turn into
you know uh your childhood circumstances
and and trauma responses
clashing um and being a ultimately
complete waste of time because i know
tim ferriss listeners
are very possessive uh about their
precious
time um this book is
a lot about how we are attracted to
people that have the negative qualities
of our primary caretakers
um i find that to be incredibly
important information just to know that
that is how we lean
in general our brains want to um
finish unfinished business in our work
life in our professional life
in our friendships we tend to be
attracted to people who have the
negative qualities of our primary
caretaker so when you're going out on
dates when you're selecting a mate
when you're selecting friends when
you're hiring employees
it's important that you understand that
that is going to be what we're attracted
to
and often when we're attracted to the
people that have the negative qualities
of our primary caretakers
uh it turns into this thing that we've
been marketed as being called
chemistry i have great chemistry with
that person but it really could just be
your inner child going
mom is that you dada
and then we end up just having our inner
child run the show and for the most part
um the people i end up working with are
not the people that i have amazing
chemistry with necessarily it's the
people that
hear me when i say something have direct
clear communication uh the people that
you work with do not have to be the
people you hang out with all the time
and text with all day
you don't have to be besties with the
people you work with i think
between these two books it's a really
good way to make sort of emotion-free
clear logical hiring
uh and partnering uh decisions so that
you're acting from your brain and not
your heart
and so your inner child's not running
the show so again i recommended
melanie beatty codependence no more
getting the love you want
from horrible hendricks and the gift of
fear survival signals that protect us
by gavin de becker
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop
in your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy